okay would you
so watching it back do you feel the same
way about her um i think when i first
watched candy's owens as we know the
institutions are very left i think i was
very deep
in my leftist side of thinking so
it doesn't bother me as it did as much
in the time i see where she's coming
from i think and one of the reasons that
i watched but i'll say we'll just talk
about this one is
i feel like in many causes
that happen that are positive that
person might actually be a fat person
who's done a lot of things and no one
really talks about that and you look and
look at about in terms of
us and uk history when you look at most
of our leaders have done some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but they only ever talk about the
good things so even though yeah don't
say george floyd was a model to society
but the fact that something positive i
would say has come out of this came out
of it that was positive i'd say
affirmative action giving people chances
i can only speak for the uk that people
wouldn't have usually happened in terms
of in the corporate work so over here we
have something called the 1975 sexual
equality act where basically means you
you can't
pick someone based on gender race
disability religion all of those
but it wasn't really being enforced and
now when you're looking now and this is
why i actually wrote my dissertation on
this in the uk black africans not
caribbeans or black africans in the uk
and indians outperformed the white
working class middle class and upper
class through primary school to
university but then when you actually
come out to get jobs black africans have
the lowest level employment throughout
so now a lot of play work places
they're
the way they're picking based on cvs i
mean they're going to get the role but
they'd actually fulfill a quota where a
certain amount of people from a certain
amount of demographics so if you're from
a single parent household if you're say
black or whatever you'd have to go a
certain amount would have to go for the
interview if you get to the interview
and you're not good enough that's good
enough point you know it's not good
enough before these people because they
didn't know people through nepotism
weren't even allowed to sit in the room
so now it's more they weren't allowed to
apply for the job no they just weren't
getting interviewed and they weren't
getting picked and that's why you're
looking at because i work in investment
management i've seen my space since the
blm more efficient minorities are being
given the opportunity because before us
i work in the people's industry so the
reality is there there's three rounds of
interviews i don't know it'll probably
be similar to you in the us you have
your vetting just to see if you're
competent for the role
then you have a thing called um star
questions where you go and you
they really test if you're really good
for the role then you have a third one
which is basically a popularity test you
go in there and people see do i want to
do i want to work with this guy if
you've gone to our you'll see your
equipment of some prep school in harvard
and yellow and then there's another guy
who's from the bronx everyone in the
office is from harvard or yeah
what are you going to pick by the way up
because i'll be honest if loads of
people from my community came for the
interview i'm going to pick the guy from
my interview so that is more getting rid
of those processes and making it more
aware so that's what i'm saying is has
leveled the playing field isn't that
racist
um well if you were to do that
or in terms of leveling the playing
field well no because aren't you
interviewing people based on like their
race no it's more it's more of a thing
of if you have the equal
grade and you have the equal but a lot
of what you said the uk cv is
educational achievement
bloody bloody blood all of that stuff
and then the rest of it is what they
really care about it's at the bottom of
it
what gets you the job is
your extracurriculars so for me i was
lucky i played like academy level
i was of a pro team playing rugby so
when i went to interviews in my space
there's loads of people that worked this
when i was going to interviews oh do you
know thingy i'm like yeah i know him he
used to coach me there
already i kind of know that that's my
way in
so it's just like a lot of people are
being judged on ah did you go to boat
school at eaton did you go and do this
at oxford when you're looking at a lot
of working class where should it be no
it's everything you shouldn't like
shouldn't you be judged on your
education yeah that's but that won't
mean it's that little part
so it was a thing of
you can say you get a thousand cvs and i
see it now a thousand cv's
of those thousand five hundred are good
enough so now when you look at the cv on
the recruitment side you're like
what
do they have that distinguishes them
from the pack because we can only
interview 20. yeah so i've didn't bid it
with recruitment where they'll be like
they'll get a woman that she comes on ah
let's go on facebook gotta say tits show
get rid of her ah this one oh he used to
do
rugby at oxford with me
uh same for rugby team i was he's
probably gonna get on with the team
because we used to do rugby there as
well so now you're picking people
for likenesses
on their extracurricular so it's got rid
of that way in the sense of okay now
they can't pick people on their extra
kilos you'd have to have to have a
certain amount so you'd have a certain
amount that would picked on that but
you'd have a certain amount where you
would have to fulfill a quota so it
gives an equal opportunity this is like
if someone who applied who was disabled
they'd be given the opportunity to get
an interview whereas before previously
in the past employers would be like
sorry he's disabled we're just not going
to employ it so now it's given everyone
an opportunity whereas before they want
it and what it comes down to when you
get to the interview
are you good enough it decides whether
you get the job yeah but like to me
that's racist why is it racist because
it's it's like you're saying to these
people they can't do it on their own
yeah but the thing is if
the whole organization is like
like i know you right
i i don't think you'd ever have a
problem getting a job
because you're driven you're smart i
don't know what's mad i did what i had
me personally i had a problem like and
when i get get into my space
because i'm from how long were you
unemployed
uh for me this is my way in
school you know it's safe i'm saying how
long you said you had a problem so how
long were you going when bef when
that's kind of typical though after
school no but what i'm saying is in my
space
when i got to places because everyone in
my space
was white middle class don't work like
don't talk like me
they they're weighing that they've known
someone who worked at goldman sachs jp
morgan yeah dad owns a yacht but i'm
just such a normal person i'm like one
of the only people who free from
nepotism hasn't come through my firm
it's almost like the question they
always ask me is like how did you get
here because people like me don't exist
don't exist in my space
and that's why it's like the guy i work
with now
he came a similar route but
we're like one of not many like when i
talk about what i do within my community
they're like what you actually got a job
in them because people like us we we're
taught from education that we don't work
in these places it's just i've seen the
effects on quotas in the us and it's
typically not like good so elaborate so
so the one the one that i think of is
schools so and the reason is like they
would do something similar with
education where they wanted more like
black people in different schools and
the problem was they were accepting
black people that weren't qualified for
the job they weren't qualified for the
school and those those black kids would
fail out you know you know where the uk
difference differs to um america see it
in america
because to me like it shouldn't matter
what you look like like i feel like the
only thing that should matter is your
qualifications and your skills and and
and honestly your extracurriculars too
like because to me it's like it's like
anything
anything more than that if you're gonna
hire someone or even interview someone
based on race like i think that's racist
and it's condescending to the people in
that race no boys is to put measures in
place to stop nepotism and the reason
why i say that say me and you now we're
content creators nepotism yeah so that's
giving favor to family and friends and
people but why why can't i give like so
i'm starting a business now i think if i
want to hire my sister over a stranger
of course i'm going to do that i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
especially if there's nothing in the
government stopping
you who like you're not related to me
right from starting your own business
yeah but then this is where it comes
with the 1975
sexual quality act where of corporations
when you get to a certain size you can't
you have to pick them based on talent
and that's the reason is because
otherwise it promotes just for the
elites and the people that maintain them
to keep hiring who they want and that's
not based on time well but even so if if
i'm if i'm the reason i would pick my
sister or my brother is because like we
come from a very driven family right
that's why i would do it and i think i
would have a better odds of getting
someone good because
like if you're raised by a productive
father it makes sense that everybody's
gonna be productive right but the thing
is you could start a business and if if
your group of friends is more productive
you're gonna out you're gonna
out-compete me
in the market that's why the market like
evens itself out when it comes to skills
i think what we're debating now is
family office versus corporation when
you're a corporation there's no linkage
there other than
your whiteness and your upbringing but
to put the problem with that is now
you're marginalizing a group where it's
basically like
from from birth
what do you mean by your whiteness
because there's corporations that are
started by people that aren't white but
the majority in the uk
of corporations or wife by the way the
majority of the uk is white isn't it um
i believe
90 percent of it is what i think so but
of directors and ceos 0.3 are of ethnic
minority there's what 0.3
of
but like the thing is you don't know why
that is but if you're looking at
but it's not academia that's not it's
not talent because if you look at no no
who outperforms all the way through the
education system it's not the right way
right but like
but the question is
it doesn't necessarily mean like my dad
wasn't very good at school he dropped
out of college but he's in the top half
a percent of earners like it doesn't
necessarily mean just because you're
good in school you're gonna make a lot
of money and a lot of times like what i
see the left argument make is there's a
disparity that ex that that it's
immediately from discrimination or like
nepotism or something when oftentimes
it's different cultures value different
things like for example i would argue
that indian americans probably
they outpace
any group in terms of income but i would
guess they're probably a lower
percentage of ceos because they tend to
be programmers
and it's just like like germans tend to
make more money because they tend to be
engineers no but i know but this is what
i'm talking about in terms of
the the stuff you can even get out the
footsie one like what puts you where i
think it's 55 100 directors or 5250 i
can't remember this is what i did my
discipline
um that is directly linked to academic
attainment this is when you're looking
at say property wealth in the uk
indians own 74 of their homes compared
to any other demographic but they don't
make they kill it everywhere yeah it's
their model which is like buy it buy up
land sell essentials and they just smash
it but when you look at say
um
blacks they have explored the academia
room
they weren't getting in they weren't
getting opportunities to even sit at the
table and that's where the conversation
was is there something stopping black
people from starting their own business
here um
in terms of
in terms of finances did they have the
available capital well if you look at in
the uk the majority of black people but
say if you wanted to start a business at
35 you've had from 18 to 35 to save to
do that now yeah that's you're
based on the predication that that
person's from a stable upbringing but if
you're no i'm not my dad that's like
because he he grew up with one of 13
kids on the south side of chicago they
had no money he he started off with like
200 000 dollars in debt but so so and he
didn't have his parents didn't own a
business nothing so so what i'm saying
is like he just made smart decisions he
didn't drink he didn't go out he got
married young he just did all the right
things but what you're talking about is
they call it the winner's curse is where
they hand pick someone say like richard
branson is oh he never got a degree and
he's a the ceo and i don't know a
conglomerate but how many other people
the majority of people with your dad's
upbringing don't have that success story
right because people coming from because
because most of them don't work 80 hours
a week
like from the time he was like 20
like i i don't work 80 hours a week i
might do like 70.
and what kind of earners your dad in
terms of percentage was probably 0.25
half a percent that's my point so your
dad you're using your dad your anecdote
as the elite and there's black men that
have done that but landslides people
coming from from your dads in the us 88
percent of 80 of millionaires are
self-made they didn't get any money so
so i'm saying like i i don't like a
quota to me is like just this is just my
perspective i think it's racist because
it's oftentimes like white liberals
saying oh to basically to minorities
they can't do it themselves and i think
a lot of times like i've talked to like
black conservatives that find them
offensive because they did it themselves
and they're like why do we need these
handouts but it's not being able to sit
at the table isn't a hand up because
you're not getting picked based on the
quote you're being given the opportunity
to have an interview when prior you
wouldn't have been able to right but to
me but that's still saying to them you
can't get an interview on your own
a lot of them can't for me i couldn't
get until i got the co-sign from a white
man that liked me i couldn't
but the way i got it is
right so you so that's what i'm saying
you you you got into because you
networked because i networked with a
white man who knows the power so that's
that's good you found someone that had
power and that happens to be the white
man because
we're in a white country
but i'm saying there's been a white
conversation what does it matter like
what he looks like like and that's the
thing like i don't understand this like
mentality where it's like oh well he's a
white man with power okay who cares like
because you have like you have
likenesses towards that person it's just
it's just like a lot of black businesses
not necessarily like i hired five people
like three of them were black and i
didn't care because last year
when you look at no but i'm sorry i i
know uk i know everyone has that people
but i'm saying i know a lot of people
that own businesses and if you make the
money money is green they don't give a
[ __ ] what you yeah as long as you're as
long as they're making the money but
what you're saying now is anecdotal
there's loads of businesses that don't
think that way no it's not just
anecdotal because i also take like into
account that 88 of millionaires in the
us were self-made
so so so what do you mean in terms of so
so like they didn't inherit any money no
i know but what why are you saying
that's not and i'm talking about in
terms of hiring now we're talking about
hiring
i'm talking about wealth creation so
yeah we're talking about wealth creation
yeah and so i'm which goes into hiring
as part of it how many of that 88
million are self-made how many of them
have any minorities in the u.s do you
know but to me like why does that matter
like that that's like the mentality i
don't get no because it's not if we're
talking quotas wise if say that of them
of
is ten percent then that would
that would equal
like per cap per capita would equal the
same when you're producing eight percent
or ten percent per the eighty days but
i'm saying it shouldn't matter because
like i i don't think like race matters
like i don't think so you it doesn't
matter to you
it shouldn't it shouldn't and i agree
with that that's me coming as a
mixed-race person like my mom's like
uh asian asian and white right that's me
coming from there my dad's bad honestly
it does the top burning income group is
india and america isn't it is indian
american in the us yeah and the uk is
the same
so it's like if there's these barriers
that were so like
like then why are indian americans able
to do it no indian americans do the uh
because to me
right because it's more about culture
but
culture their culture
in terms of attainment is
indians do where the gujaratis when they
go to
tanzania they go to kenya they do the
same thing theirs is pick up a shop
owner shop
con consumer staples just become the
masters of that no not in the us they're
all they're programmers oh and over here
is consumer students yeah they just well
i'm just saying their culture is very
much like hard work
and so it's like my question is and i
mean i could be wrong but it's just like
my question is like if indian americans
can do it in all these different places
like i don't understand like why other
groups need handouts like because to me
like i think that's racist because it's
basically liberal saying you can't do it
on your own
whether it's an interview whether it's a
school application what like it's all
the same concept
but when you look at exactly i can talk
about the uk yeah there was policies and
we'll get him up because eddie was the
one that told me about it there was
policies at the time because in a lot of
people in the u from the commonwealth
so that was jamaica and well a lot of
the caribbean and india came to the uk
in the commonwealth from the
commonwealth in the wind rush so i was
around i think the 60s
and there was actually policies at the
time where a lot of the corner shops in
the uk are owned by indians and not
by
the caribbeans that came because
at the time the government gave out
policies where mortgages would be handed
out to indians rather than to
the black carabiners well see i would
say that's wrong too because again i
think like any policy based on race is
wrong
whether it's like
even if it's too late
level the playing field they call it
affirmative action yeah i understand the
intention it's just the a lot of times
like and like the path to hell is paved
the road to hell is paved on good
intentions and like i just think that
like if you're giving something to
someone based on race that is racist but
it's not you're not being given it you
still have to you're just being given
the opportunity and that's where i think
we have in a different city
even even if it's opportunity i think if
you are giving someone an interview
based on race that is racist just like i
think if someone was saying oh i'm only
going to interview white people i think
that's racist no but people this is my
point is people
this is now being openly put but people
will do that and have been doing that
just without overtly saying rich people
no i'm saying people before these
policies before the 1975 equality yeah
white companies were employing white
people way more than they were playing
any other ethnic group but when that was
put in place and
rules were put in place to tell people
that whether because a lot of people
talk about overt racism in the sense of
maybe racism in the world i'm talking
about prejudice acting on prejudice
everyone acts on prejudice so can i vote
can i talk to you the first thing you
said though you said white companies
were hiring white people but 90 of the
uk is white and you don't know why they
were hiring white people so it's like
the automatic assumption that it's
racism when you don't know certain
cultures want to do different things but
like you type in the 1975 equality and
we can do it now and if you see how
employment actually spikes within
marginalized groups that that says it
all that people won't be given
opportunities because why suddenly
they're being employed because they they
now have the job so they obviously have
the talent because they're doing the job
so you wouldn't hire them if you didn't
have the talent you have to have the
talent towards a job but i'm saying if
they had quotas wouldn't they
automatically
and then it's like where does it end
when when are we equal that's the
question
sexually
75 race racers
i do because that one's just women
there's one that's like sexual it's like
race
sexism
science race
ages when you did your dissertation did
you look at um
no no so i'm curious did you look up
like the number of black people in the
uk did it go up over time too
like like because it was for it was for
what caribbean or african you said
um that was who it was protect like who
who gets the quotas oh yeah go down my
phone my sister said that to me
one because the other thing is like a
lot of times they'll attribute one
policy to another thing when you don't
know if um
if like that that group increased in
general in the uk
like if they had more migrant like if
more people immigrated here i think it
was based on quote from everybody let me
get a
i have a question so wait do you think
it should be illegal for you if you
wanted to do a black only business